[Music]
in maybe not news maybe not [ __ ]
submitted by Debbie Davi
so nothing Dennis Rodman is taking
credit for otto warmbier release the guy
that died Oh what the hell yeah the guy
the guy that took the thing from the
Madonn one Colleen the one college kids
that jacked the propaganda and then they
imprison him there I thought you just
over oh it looks the children wait wait
wait then all these information tell me
where the [ __ ] is crazy so Otto was in
North Korea and he was there with the
truth like with the church and so the
government claims that he stole a
propaganda poster from his only section
but I mean like they beat up
surveillance video and it just looks
like a blob that has like arms and legs
you can't even tell what it
so anyways point is they imprison him
they sentence him to 15 years of hard
labor and then that's when they were
like alright we'll release him back to
the US whoops we're releasing him
because he's actually in a coma he's
really sick he ate some bad nachos I
remember that one no he claimed that he
got botulism which you can get from
canned not too much hoes cuz we did talk
about a story of someone else I got that
so anyway he very claiming that he got
much wisdom he ends up getting to the US
and then she dies and so they're saying
that he had severe brain damage and I
just looked really shady like they did
some [ __ ] over there and so Dennis
Rodman he just came back from North
Korea and he kind of get like claiming
credit for Otto's release because he's
saying like he's older a lot doesn't he
amen amen the leaders type yeah their
pets gauri he says that their lifelong
friend Dennis Rodman you are such a
piece of [ __ ] why is he not why is he
our ambassador like how come him
michaelis Ryland you know that's the
most odd [ __ ] in the world yes Dennis
Rodman and Carl little salty looks like
dude he looks like what it does Nia
Botox on an ellipsis [ __ ] Larsen
peaceful guy nestled exactly an
even-aged of my ass agent like
basketball you do um I'm not sure if an
agent his agent
nah he's the one that has been arranging
all those trips over to my friend scare
the agent was saying in this interview I
was saying that he he asked North Korean
officials three times on behalf of
Dennis Rodman if they can release auto
so that's why it's answer I mean kind of
cleaning credit because they were like
well yeah right when we're there to be
release him it was it kind of worked out
the same way yeah what if does Brahman
is the real one making moves out there
Korea and in the government how does he
do anything tsunami hilarious he's just
getting his in right now
you got botulism that kid yeah but uh
but yeah he's saying that Dennis Rodman
saying that no one knew that he was sick
and he was just like really happy when
he found out that the kid was released I
he was like jumping up and down and just
really happy and then like he was also
saying that the the dictators really
misunderstood do you mean with others
all that like Curtin North Korea is a
wonderful place everyone was really
happy now things have changed and I
believe it why because it's Dennis
Rodman he does have a track record yeah
she [ __ ] Carmen Electra anybody that
[ __ ] Carmen Electra I believe prints and
then it's ramen to heroes of mine
goodness da-jung Princeton cities Dennis
Rodman is an interesting guy because
right now he looks like a parrot fish
or some kind of you know the sunfish
yeah with a big old lips and in the room
and if sunglasses look like Cee Lo Green
it's just so scary to me that like he
keeps going back and forth and like he's
are so comfortable like dude we don't
really know anything about it we don't
know nobody there's also information
that we get from North Korean defects
their escape and their telling about
like the horror stories also I know like
friends who have relatives that are
there you know what I mean so it's like
I don't know about that I mean he gets
all the good stuff because he's hanging
out with royalty so they cater probably
does see it yes amazing characters I
mean there's a another friend of mine
too like uh I shouldn't like hold it I'm
not you know Ella holding it because
like I I don't like his ignorant so for
example he decided he he got married to
a girl who was in the Philippines but
she's very well-off right and then his
perception of the world is very skewed
because he comes from money so he's like
oh like yeah this little business as bad
as most people think Bob that's really
great over here I was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about dude this is a
[ __ ] impoverished country what are
you saying but his view is like he sees
the world through her eyes because she's
very well-off you know so it made me
lose a lot of respect for the guy
because he can't see passes over wealth
you know what I mean
because I know friends who parents are
actually missionaries in the Philippines
and they see like a majority of what the
country goes through you know what I
mean that's kind of just like bondage
man like that that's true for teens
about taking Dennis Rodman and saying K
so this village nobody exactly everyone
here just you know they starve to that
let me take you to this other factory
where everyone just works for two cents
a day let me take you to this other
place right here yeah all running water
over here everybody's got to drink the
silver [ __ ] this pile pile of sand or
from that idea for your sandwich but I
mean that's choose any country though
like when tourists come to LA the best
yeah no one goes taste can let me take
it too skinny bro in downtown electro
Mike you
yeah let me take you straight to the
[ __ ] areas where everyone smokes
crack all day and people take a dump on
the street let me take a bath for human
dumped everywhere yep no one no one no
one does that like the tour guide
doesn't do that but that would be a good
idea yeah so dinner drama in that
interview here staying close we've seen
a lot of changes to the country are you
guys so modernized now him an Avenger
when you go over there and you hear the
radio and people are talking they're so
happy now because it's like I feel more
like I know it's civilize again because
it's so modern that you can hear the
radio used to say like you could hear
the radio people are talking they're so
happy because it's more civilized again
really are still median it's still like
a form of propaganda there all the other
stuff where people have gone there
they've recorded and taking footage out
of what it's like over there you know I
mean where they kind of like skew all
that information to make us believe how
amazing it is
yeah confuse them like I don't see the
whole politics stuff about it I just
think cancer might as a person like we
we bond we sing karaoke together we go
ride horses we have fun we do all this
stuff he's a cool guy just people
misunderstand hands knows anything we
got a [ __ ] [ __ ] I think you should
stay in North Korea forever yeah he's
also there he was also saying in this
interview that he was Donald Trump
supporter and he's saying he's like it's
the politics that's the bad thing if we
can try to figure something out just
open the door if Donald Trump had a
chance he would fly to North Korea and
try to make peace I'll ask them right
now Donald come talk to me let's try to
work this out who does it want are you I
get nothing animus the only thing I get
out of pride for my country America I
love America favorite I shut the [ __ ]
the White House direct text line I know
[ __ ] are you bro shut up [ __ ] up that
was lucky I'm not gonna lie
years ago I was at a met this is Otto
the student that has now poured Auto
sauce mrs. Dennis with the leader over a
North Korean suit and then here he is
kids he's saying that all these chips
North Korea like this is most recent
trip he said he didn't get to hang out
with Kim Jong but he was just there to
promote like port and childlike have
forth go like American sports go over
there and then vice versa
have North Korea come out that's what
his main bowl is to do talk about sport
when it's ignorant bliss is the kissing
kind of a good reason we have no
communication really with them and I
mean the two governments are always kind
of like feuding yeah dislike well I got
this missile pointing at you so do i and
is like well maybe we could enjoy a
basketball game that's what that's a
kind of step you know yeah you guys to
be gone and going to North Korea
no just to visit I don't think I know
cuz I said some [ __ ] and we watch soon
as I [ __ ] get there because you know
what I check where the views come from
and we do have views from North Korea
one or two on some videos oh [ __ ] it
could also be a VPN blocker so Kim
Jungman just like watching really pissed
off well we should say I'll be pretty
[ __ ] funny dude if I go to North
Korea and they look immediately we're
saying oh my god
Kim Jong Keela that'd be so cool
oh no I a part of me is kind of envious
I still am jealous what he was Kim Jong
hyung oh I thought of Dennis Rodman from
oh but he come on man
it's better than having a company you
have a country yeah a lot of people
dying well he would have run it like
that though I don't know this Damali
Ataka people are dying in the US every
[ __ ] day people in the US die from
overeating people in North Korea die
from under eating same [ __ ] people in
North Korea have to [ __ ] serve in the
military people in America play killing
games all day same [ __ ] so how would you
solve some of the problems in North
Korea I would just pretend that there
are none that's what you do it David so
complex everybody's doing I don't know I
just I just feel like we always got a
[ __ ] demonized certain groups and be
like you guys are [ __ ] evil they
don't want to take over the US they just
want to keep their little hermit Kingdom
that's all they want to do that gives me
a chance to go over there and take it
over but first I got to learn North
Korean hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos check it out up here
[Music]
[Music]